I did not hit her it's not true it's
bullshit I did not hit her
I did not oh hi mark I love my eyes I
didn't miss anything
that's what time
welcome to a very unique and special
hilarious 'ti I've wanted to make this
video for quite some time and I just
couldn't quite figure out the right time
to do it but since Indiana Jones five
has been officially announced by Steven
Spielberg starring Harrison Ford now's
the perfect time to rip myself a new
asshole that's right when I was a
teenager my friends and I worked very
hard to create - Indiana Jones movies we
made one called Indiana Jones and the
jewel of the forest it was about 40
minutes long then we made another one
called Indiana Jones in the eyes of
eternity and that one was actually about
an hour long we were always very proud
of our work even though it's not very
good but the fun for us to look back on
and have memories and remember filming
those events and remember the scars that
I still have yeah we were also really
dumb we did really dumb things like
dangerous stunts that we should have
never tried to attempt with no help and
no supervision and no professionals I'm
actually surprised we're still here to
be completely honest we were very
reckless but hey it's gonna make for
some fun entertainment now but I'm going
to take you back to when I was about 17
years old and we started work on Indiana
Jones and the jewel of the forest our
movie opened with a very Raiders of the
Lost Ark vibe I'm creeping through the
woods with my buddy isaku who's sort of
like a hand-me-down shortround and we
are looking for my hat my hat has been
stolen and it's time to find my hat
because it's Indiana Jones's hat the
thing that I'm most proud of about this
scene is that we actually have real live
scorpions a friend of mine provided his
scorpions for us to use in this scene
and I did a stunt with one of the
scorpions on my shoulder
it was a lot of fun it was slightly
nerve-racking that's for sure but I did
feel like we were doing something a
little bit more legit than I had up
until that point with the short films we
had there making it felt just a little
bit more legit
let's go and one of our biggest
struggles when we made films back in the
day were to like figure out how to
elongate the opening credits I wrote all
of them I starred in them I directed
them and my friend starred in them and
then everything else was done by me I
edited them I did everything I set up
the shots and so it was like how do I
make these credits any longer so you get
things like edited with iMovie I mean we
we were trying guys we we tried okay we
we tried it was kind of fun for me to
play this because I got to act really
grumpy and drag my friend around and
look I have a grumpy side like every
everybody does but I do have a grumpy
side like if I haven't slept well I get
grumpy like in the past that's been very
obvious whenever I've been on a podcast
or something and I've been up for like a
long time I get cranky it's it's just
it's a problem I have trust me I know so
it was kind of fun to portray an overly
grumpy character dragging my friend
around through the points
the one thing that I am still proud of
with these two films are that we
actually did try to make the action look
as good as we could we worked hard to
make the punching and the fighting and
everything look as best as it could with
what we had no stunt team you know that
kind of stuff didn't you get enough back
at the bar Jones
you
we got cut up a lot and lots of scrapes
and bruises and I still actually do have
scars on all my knuckles from a stunt
that I'll talk to about in a minute so I
get back my hat and we get this
incredibly over-the-top epic scene where
I put the hat on because Indiana Jones
why did you come back I wouldn't have
come back you hadn't have taken this
so the basic plot of this little movie
we made is that this gang that lives in
a forest kidnaps my friend isaku and
steals this very rare jewel then
challenges Indiana Jones to like this
Game of Death scenario where he has to
go through all these challenges and
India accepts and he goes to Nicaragua
which really resembles the forest in my
backyard oh boy and we tried to build
some suspense here because India is
looking for this gang and they gave him
no directions they just said Nicaragua
so so fairly I just knew to go to like
Nicaragua like oh here I am in this
place they're probably around here
somewhere in this big place so like I
said we used all natural lighting
so there's many sequences in this movie
where the sunlight changes drastically I
mean it's like samurai cop level bad
like back and forth you can tell we
filmed on different days so Indy tracks
down the SACU he's being held by this
evil leader who's challenging me to all
of these events and the main villain of
the movie is played by a friend of mine
who doesn't really want his likeness
shown in videos he's been clear to me
about that in the past and that's cool
so to respect him I'm not going to show
his face in this video but he challenges
me to all these fights and the first one
is this guy who clearly has a very real
beard that's definitely not fake that's
a real beard he grew himself and this
fight was a lot of fun and this is the
fight that I got really banged up in
because we had this moment where he was
going to attach my whip to my wrists and
start dragging me on the ground and I
was like let's just do it little did I
know that what we were standing in was
actually eventually going to be paved
and they had already paved it I just saw
a lot of dirt everywhere but that dirt
had blown across this asphalt over the
months because they hadn't yet done
anything with this area that we of
course didn't have permission to film in
so when he started dragging me it became
apparent that I was not being dragged
across dirt I was actually being dragged
across asphalt that just had dirt on top
of it and I still have scars for my
knuckles being scraped against the
asphalt and to my horror I realized oh
crap I planned three more shots
we did him we did it anyway for this
shot we had the rope attached to the end
of a car and my friend sat inside the
trunk of the car and filmed outside the
car while my other friend drove the card
like ten miles an hour that was a
terrifying actually
and I'm proud that we did that stunt
despite the fact you can actually see in
this shot that my knuckles are bleeding
after I get dragged I have this moment
where you think I'm about to get stabbed
and then I do the Indiana Jones big
comeback moment you know and I just call
it the punch montage because I just
unload on this guy
so I beat up that guy real good and then
the next challenge is ninjas these
ninjas just appear
despite the fact that the end product of
this movie is not amazing and there's so
many technical flaws and audio issues
and horrible horrible acting I remember
smelling the pine needles in that forest
I remember the actual event of filming
it and so even though you watch it now
you're like oh shit that's horrible
I remember being there and just being
inspired by making films with my friends
so after I beat up the ninjas I go to
save my friend and I save him kinda but
I really just end up chasing the guy
everywhere and we had a cool idea here
we were like hey there's a road that
goes through the woods right here so how
about we get the car and we sit in the
car and film outside the window and we
go like about 10 15 miles an hour and
you run as fast as you can by the car so
we can actually get like a side panning
shot that like you know we can have the
technology to do any of that with
the finale of this movie is where I was
just really dumb I don't know what I was
thinking but we did it and I somehow
survived we have all these crazy stunts
involving this truck I dive out of the
way before the truck hits me there was a
fair amount of distance there but it's
later when I get on top of the truck and
then start hanging on the front of it
while my friend is driving through the
woods and I was just realizing to myself
watching this what the hell was I
thinking there was like no supervision I
was just we just were like do it just
get the shot do it why not when you have
scorpions at your disposal you use them
when you have a truck in the woods you
use it when you have a friend who is
strong enough to pull you across the
asphalt you do it that's making films oh
boy this movie is not good at all but
you know what we tried we fucking tried
this took us about three months to make
and it was tons of fun we spent an
entire summer doing this movie so
eventually my friend gives up the jewel
because he's like you're you're too good
he's like a DI Jones you're just too
good here's the jewel amazing ending um
of our film oh my god okay oh there's
another one I think yeah we made a
second one the second one we worked a
lot hard to run as I said earlier this
one was about an hour long and this one
took us six months to make and we
actually went out of state to film this
one we went to Pennsylvania where our
friends own this cabin because we were
looking for places we could film in that
were period piece worthy but you know
not the forest because it's like where
else do you film nowadays unless it's
the forest if you want to have it be
like the 1930s so our friends had this
cabin and it was perfect so we filmed
there as well so similar the first one
there was no Steadicam no lights no
microphones it was all natural lighting
and those are just really fancy ways to
say we didn't work hard enough we this
one opens with this train track fight
sequence and we always had to wait for
the train to come back because it would
pass us really quickly and then we would
have to read
start another angle as soon as the next
train came to keep the illusion that a
train was passing by because we couldn't
get every shot obviously with one train
so we had to actually sit around all day
and continue to wait for trains to come
by so that we could finish the terrain
fight oh my god and we're not even
really supposed to be there my dad used
to work on the railroad back in the day
he was actually a train conductor and
when he watched that he said yeah it's
kind of illegal you're not actually
supposed to be on the track so I was
like oh well we got a train in the movie
dad production value production value
the Train they can't stop the train just
because we're not supposed to be there
so film it now this movie takes place in
South Africa also known as my backyard
so Indy sidekick isaku is back in this
movie and we're going to this cabin to
stay for a while I really don't know why
I think it's supposed to be like it's
our place we crash at I don't really
know I'm the writer I don't even know
why we're going there so uh but the
worst ninja in the world breaks into
this cabin and this fight scene erupts
and we had fun doing this because we
were able to film a fight scene in a
enclosed environment with no mosquitoes
biting us every two seconds so that was
definitely a plus
Johnson to me the whip what
the whip throw me to win what Moochie on
again Oh
oh hey J stay with him after this guy
falls on an axe we find these drawings
it followed an axe oh my god we find
these drawings inside his pockets that I
obviously drew and they're like these
shapes and I say it's something about
this sato beto tribe this tribe i made
up that sounds like it's right out of a
spent era when nature calls check
Shawshank Redemption Chicago you're out
of there I opened up a dictionary for a
big exposition scene that explains what
the site Obito Warriors were and of
course wow this dictionary has an
article about them
I wonder who wrote that and I wonder who
drew the picture of the site of beto
warrior it's clearly not me so there's
this mask called the eyes of eternity
that the Sato beto warriors possess if
you stare into its eyes you see your
future so it's very sought-after but
there's also a legend that if you
attempt to wear the mask you can gain
higher power higher intelligence or you
could vanish off the earth and go to
someplace amazing or like heavenly you
know whatever it's just the weird story
about the mask that I made humph and
these sought to be toe warriors have the
ability to touch you and drain the life
force out of you just by touching you so
that's kind of that that's that's not
inspired by temple of doom at all
there's definitely no temple of doom
inspiration in this film especially not
later when my friend and I stumble
across the saw to be toe warriors and
he's like raising his hand up towards
the thing and he touches the guy and he
dies like there's no temple of doom
inspiration there at all so we set out
to find this tribe and we filmed this at
this place called Virginia Kendall
because there's all these really cool
ledges here and we were able to film in
all these really neat locations but
unfortunately there's also a lot of
hikers there so I would say at least 50%
of the time we were doing a shot
somebody was like hey what are you guys
doing the sad part is we can't do
anything about it because we obviously
didn't have right
or a permit to film there and so that's
one of the the hardships of independent
filmmaking also there were these really
cool carvings there in the stone so I
decided to write this whole scene where
we'd stumble across these things I
called hieroglyphics you know but they
were really just like this art done by
somebody who had gone through there but
we utilized it in the movie so we
stumble across the eyes of eternity mask
and I go towards it and it actually does
show me my future and I show a whole
bunch of little things about what will
eventually happen later in the film
moments that later actually do happen
and then this big fight scene erupts
that I actually really screwed up my
thumb there's this one take where I
actually mistakingly punched my friend
right in the face you can't quite tell
because this really quick watch
but he then like kind of went backwards
and his shoe went up in the air and kind
of bent my thumb back really far so for
the rest of that scene if you look
really closely you can see that I'm kind
of holding my fist like that like
holding my thumb so that you can't see
how swollen it was because I actually
couldn't bend Ike this is about as far
as I could bend it for like a week the
worst part of this movie by far is the
awkward dialogue cutting you can really
tell that I would turn the camera and
say okay say your line cut turn the
camera okay say your line cut and then I
did that over and over again without
doing like a whole bunch of takes at
once so you can really feel the awkward
flow of dialogue just not feeling
natural that's by far the worst part of
this movie aside from the obvious
technical issues for the most part I'm
okay with the majority of the action
sequences that we tried to accomplish in
this film because for the last half of
the movie after we're captured by this
tribe it's nonstop action and my friends
and I did a lot of really crazy stuff
this big fight scene erupts with my
buddy who loved doing this because he
got to pick me up and throw me into a
river
which actually was a very dangerous
stunt because I didn't even check the
river really there could have been
jagged rocks I could have been like
impaled but I didn't check because you
know we got to get the shot I don't know
what I was thinking really I was like I
think I was about 18 here maybe almost
19 but we tried I keep saying that but
it's true we did try this fight scene
was fun though because they lodged this
thing in my back
it was obviously like my my take on the
Temple of Doom voodoo sequence and they
had this thing that presses a button and
it sends like electric shocks through me
so we had this big thing where like he
pressed the button every once a while
made me have like electric shock
problems it was fun to film it was
enjoyable and we had like the big
Indiana Jones moment you know because
like every movie has the big Indiana
Jones moment where he gets pummeled a
lot and then he comes back this was our
moment
here we get to the dumbest thing we did
by far I got dragged behind a car got
dragged behind a truck got thrown into a
river this is by far the dumbest thing
we did we had actual real machetes and
we did sword fights with them these are
not fake machetes and one of them is
rusty and jagged and I did actually get
cut on my knuckle so another fight scene
erupts between isaku and this sought to
be toe warrior and this was fun because
we had about 30 minutes and we just ran
into this forest somewhere you can
actually hear some kids playing on swing
sets in a playground nearby for a few
shots and my one friend was able to do
all these flips we actually got a couple
really cool stunts out of that
this next fight was a lot of fun because
it was this really quick thing we did
with these guards we tried really hard
there's a swordfight moment that we
choreographed it looks rigid as hell
like really rigid but that's because
there's a real machetes and we were like
oh shit if we mess up even slightly I
could possibly actually slice you up
with a machete so again we were dumb and
we did it but it resulted in that like a
classic little Indiana Jones laughing
funny moment you'll see at the end
we tried we tried our best what we had
and that's all I can really say about
this the shots don't look very good the
lighting is awful it's very low def
there's tons of out-of-focus shots but
we did try and we did finish it and
that's something that I do take pride in
because it was hard to make this movie
the finale this film involves a gigantic
ladder that was metal that we had to
drag into the woods and I'm not
exaggerating I would say it was probably
about at least 150 pounds and we had it
in this big box and we had to drag it
into the woods and we actually did
attach it to this tree and hang it over
a Ledge and have this big finale
fighting on it that was obviously a
ripoff for the end of Temple of Doom and
it was a lot of fun like it was hard and
I'll never forget that day and I
probably lost five pounds that day just
from the sweat of carrying that ladder
around the woods but we had a good time
with it and the film ends with Sato bull
the main villain putting the mask on
because he wants ultimate power and of
course he vanishes and he kind of
vanishes in a very painful way coughing
a lot
but initially I had a much more violent
death I was going to have his face melt
and we actually did it okay face melting
effect but it never went into the movie
but I still have this shot so the film
ends with Indiana Saku putting his hat
on staring off into the distance and you
know yeah the Etta Jones
and those are my Indiana Jones films I
made when I was a kid they are not good
but I look at them with joy you know why
because we finished them we worked on
him and we finished them my friends and
I got together over a total of nine
months to make those movies we worked on
the writing we we we tried we actually
really tried and so for that reason I do
feel pride when I watch them because we
were teenagers and we didn't have much
at our disposal honestly the budget for
both of those films I would say combined
maybe a hundred bucks I would say and
just for some of the costumes and the
Indiana Jones jacket was given to me by
somebody my shirt I bought at a thrift
store the satchel also at a thrift store
the most expensive item was probably the
Hat I'm just happy we made them and I'm
glad to share them with you guys because
I've been requested to show those a lot
and that kind of lets you know a little
bit more about me that I do care about
filmmaking I have tried
we have tried as youngsters you know we
really tried to make something obviously
ten years later now we try harder and we
work a little bit harder but we still
enjoy it
and we enjoyed it then and it's one of
those things where I just really wanted
to share that side of my life with you
guys because it's easy for me to sit
here a lot and just talk shit about
other people's movies and that's the
easy thing to do you know it's easier to
be a film critic than to be a filmmaker
and I'm fully aware of that and that's
something that I don't want to ever be
prideful about because I it's it's easy
what I do is easy compared to actually
making the movie and now that you guys
have seen this you know that I
understand that that's something I
really understand and I hope that in
some way anyone out there who watches
this can take away the fact that even if
you're making a movie that you think
maybe is not very professional or isn't
turning out that good finish it just
just finish it because years later you
will look back and be happy that you
finished the film even though it was
tough to do and even though it might not
be really all that great at all you
finished it and that's something you can
always have no one can take that away
from you you deserve to feel prideful
about that because you worked hard on it
so anyone out there making movies keep
making movies
I understand what you feel like I really
do it's tough we've made a lot more just
besides these and maybe one day maybe
one day I'll talk to you about my
feature-length film the woods that I
made when I was I believe 16 I want to
say 16 that one was 84 minutes long and
maybe when I hit a million guys thank
you so much as always for watching you
are the best happy filmmaking
thank you very much if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes